au nouvel élan pour le mouvement de
mobilisation dans les rues de plusieurs
villes françaises ils ont marché contre
la réforme des retraites mais aussi
beaucoup contre les méthodes du
président Macron un message qui a voulu
relayer cet employé d'une centrale
nucléaire du Nord de la France moi je
l'invite à venir vivre ma vie pendant 8
jours et puis il me dirait s'il aura
encore envie de travailler à 64 ans il
nous dira si les Français c'est des
fainéant après une baisse d'affluence la
semaine dernière une présence record a
été observée dans plusieurs
rassemblements à travers le pays des
grèves ont aussi touché plusieurs
secteurs de l'économie des voies ferrées
et des raffineries bloquées et des
écoles occupées le tout une semaine jour
pour jour après l'annonce du
gouvernement de l'imposition de son
projet de loi sans passer par le vote
des députés on a l'impression de pas été
goûté de pas être entendu de pas être
voilà de pas être compris en tout cas il
a un objectif lui c'est de le faire
passer et point c'est tout même s'ils
ont moins d'outils en main les syndicats
réclament toujours le retrait de cette
législation or si on entrevue hier le
président Emmanuel Macron s'est dit
favorable à discuter d'autres enjeux
liés au travail comme la pénibilité de
certains métiers il tient à cette
réforme même que selon lui elle devrait
entrer en vigueur d'ici la fin de
l'année ce qui pourrait calmer le jeu
c'est le retrait dans la forme le
problème c'est que le président Macron
s'y oppose frontalement et ce
frontalement appelle une escalade et la
question de voir jusqu'où l'escalade va
nous mener au départ calme la
manifestation parisienne a donné lieu à
des épisodes tendus parfois violents
les affrontements entre manifestants et
policiers ont aussi eu lieu à Nantes et
Rennes à Bordeaux l'entrée de la mairie
a été incendié
des scènes qui s'ajoutent au débordement
observés depuis plusieurs soirs dans les
manifestations spontanées organisées
dans différentes villes des épisodes
liés à des protestataires qui ne
répondent pas à l'appel au calme des
grands syndicats le dés
espoir que ça
nous faisons tous au sein des syndicats
pour que rien rien ne dégénère mais
lorsqu'on a des gens qui sont des
pyromanes
que voulez-vous faire les syndicats ont
appelé à une autre journée de
mobilisation mardi mais à partir de
maintenant la forme que prendra le
mouvement contestation semble plus
difficile à prévoir ici rafale Bouvier
au clair Radio-Canada Paris